[Musique]
mon permis oui elle permet déjà je le
découpe et il reste plus que quatre
points
vous avez six points vous venez dans
peau mais deux on est d'accord on avait
atteint le premier non mais c'est pas
encore au procès vous pas d un point
vous reste cinq points attendez-vous je
n'ai pas bougé pas bougé pas juste un
poil est là vous venez de perdre
monsieur deux points mais alléluia il
vous en reste 4 d'accord il a mordu
wayne on va le chap et non non c'est non
c'est mon beau frère en chef donc bah
oui c'est le mari de ma soeur on n'a pas
lu mais la famille on seraient cousins
belges vous mettrez qu'un point mais là
je suis en mai 2 mais pas moi j'ai pas
le procès le procès verbal quoi voulez
qu'on s'arrange donner sens à conlie
kids on n'en parle plus jaro ses
collègues 50 ha non rien du tout mais
dit j'ai pas dit on après j'ai bien dit
cela lorsque vous avez chez pas moi
j'avais pas un truc pour mes gosses
alain tiendra ses engagements de
parasols on en parle plus on de bras ça
vaut le coup oui ça vaut le coup oui
bravo parce que je pourrais me faire
virer la police 1 pour ça les gens
cliquent voilà voilà
il est bien il tient bien moi s'en
servir bon bah c'est super alors être
content 1 pourquoi ne comprends pas je
comprends qu'on n'a pas compris
puisqu'on apprenait comment le parasol
mais monsieur vous préférez bah oui
préféré regarder dans la grange
j'ai une roue de secours un canot
pneumatique de draps de bain j'ai fait
une bonne journée aujourd'hui
d'après louis kg sur la plage des
classes
allez ça va vous avez mordu la ligne
blanche vous avez vu non parce que c'est
mal foutu on est obligé de la mordre au
carrefour qui allait les trucs de
pierre-alain qui bloque on s'était
installé le truc je sais comment ça
marche bonjour m bouton
les éléments du l'alignement pourtant je
regardais bien et puis vous avez marqué
mon stop et puis les mondiaux têtu c'est
mal foutu ça parce que l'homme mais ils
foncent à des difficultés pour baiser
les gens quoi parce que là où vous savez
ce que vous perdez la seule permis c'est
combien de points dit le sait pas faire
les deux points pour ça aujourd'hui
monoï sursis ça va vite ça les piles à
comme ils vous ont repéré au top au
talkie walkie
moi je suis obligé de vous mettre la
mode c'est dégueulasse mais même moi en
tant que conducteur ça me choque et je
suis obligé de le faire parce que vous
faites ça faisait trois jours à la plage
je n'ai plus de permis malin alors
est-ce que vous avez la ceinture vous
n'allez pas y vous êtes prudente à la
visite et puis vous perdez deux points
quand même défaut de présentation des
papiers
excusez moi autant pour moi je n'essaie
pas de point ses trois points de vous
tourner à trois points si je fais le
tour de la voiture c'était de retrouver
un quatrième de points je ne fais pas ce
que vous voulez qu'on essaie d'arranger
ça avec les collègues
franchement
en fait pas si vous avez l'argent sur
vous voulez vous arranger ça sans
arroser les flics
c'est ce que vous allez pas vous allez
aller chez vous et vous allez prendre
205 en liquide parce qu'il faut arroser
tout le car n'a tort on va faire la
distrib ça va faire cinq ans à chacun
moi je prends rien sur vous parce que
vous mettez sympathique et comme ça ils
vont laisser tomber d'accord
prenez pas des billets marqué un des
numéros qui suivent parce que ça les
énerve
voilà pour les des billets sur des
choses comme ça et puis ramenée à +2
pinard aussi de trois bouteilles de rosé
ah bah c'est comme ça on fonctionne
comme ça on est en démocratie non
récurrents la ramener du vin quand même
et puis pile journal éventuellement et
pour moi vous me prenez une cartouches
de marlboro simplement
ou alors c'est ce qu'on va faire moi je
vais arroser le collègue me donner 200
francs de la main à la main chaude en
cinq ans et puis je fais 100 francs pour
moi et puis comme ça c'est bon disque
est très bas
non merci ça va pour se précise la
prochaine fois où pour les 400 francs
parce qu'il y aura les collègues
la prévision est la preuve
je me repose sur wii non c'est pas grave
comme ça nous ça nous fera des ronds
pour picoler tout c'est bon c'est mieux
pour nous je vous assure c'est bon faut
normalement six 17 balles mois après bon
je vous resto tu veux te voir un coup
avec une gamine et j'ai des frais quoi
c'est bon c'est bon parce est passé est
passé
alors deux adultes un chien 53 tu viens
de parler de ça bonjour voulez vous
mettre à poil d'accord vous allez vous
faire [ __ ] ou pas
non c'est parce que c'est un supplément
si vous faites monter sur la plage voilà
d'accord
rien non je regarde le prix dignité que
denis renaud non sésame pour garder
[ __ ] c'est quoi c'est un bel orage et
jamais vu ça voilà non mais non allez-y
combien de jours vous êtes chez marcel
roy tient toujours fait attention
faites attention
non c'est pas ça c'est que marcel a un
fils qui a été dans un hôpital
psychiatrique pendant 15 ans il est
sorti hier il a assassiné des touristes
qui dormait à la ferme il a été 15 ans
en hôpital psychiatrique qu'il a il est
rentré hier donc la nuit vous fermer la
porte à clé
d'accord parce que ce serait con là il
est rentré hier ce serait con qu un
couple comme vous égorgez la nuit rendez
compte ils séparation moi jamais je
serai dans le marché du jet mais
attendez mais marcel il est sympa mais
le fils je les ai vus ne voulait pas lui
rod et là c'est la nuit qui sort surtout
ils s'enferment dans la chambre la
journée il au premier permet bien mais
les temps qui les ouvre avec son que
terre
oui
un couple baya 15 ans qu'au début de
quand ils ont ouvert ou au camping à la
ferme quand les premières années il a
égorgé un couple de hollandais
il est il a violé la voiture à vendre il
a égorgé le couple de hollandais et des
malades ces mecs je sais de quoi je
parle c'est mon frère alors est malade
[Musique]
il est sorti et on verra un faux virer
ce soir s'il est guéri
allez bonne bourre je suis content nous
a reconnu je pourrais le dire aux
journalistes versée il a expliqué mme li
layton eye for your mother it's my first
le sun is good ofac my mother mais les
bleus thank you think you would suck my
geek
non ok secondes noces en asie tokyo
ok alors à bon c'est connu c'est non et
ce à quoi il fait une émission le
dimanche soir
comment tu sais thierry ardisson qui
dirige les missions et lui fait partie
de l'émission
non mais c'est une blague bien sûr et
puis c'est ça fait deux fois qu'on me
dise à cette semaine bien thériault il
fait du micro-trottoir commandes ils
interrogent des gens il leur pose des
questions d'ailleurs se fait pas
toujours aux jambes et enfin bon ça
c'est quelque chose mais vous devez
resservez vraiment ressembler à laurent
bassiste comme a dit fonder ce ziti de
tu devrais aller faire le sosie
on l'a déjà dit ça il est sympa ce mec
bon on m'a dit que c'est un connard un
peu
[Musique]
trop directe ouais bah l'embauché vous
dites oui si je frappe mais si je crois
que
alors par nature il serait un peu
prétentieux c'est un petit monsieur je
prends quel connard ces mec de la télé
jeux suivants passeur on m'a dit qu'ils
aient des prétentieux et moi j'ai dit
ces mecs là il faut trois émissions ils
prennent la grosse tête en plus et c'est
un mec arrogant
on m'a dit dans la vie c'est vrai je
ressemble mais vraiment sans les
lunettes ou vraiment ça se trouve c'est
moi ça se trouve un vous en dites quoi
vous le cola prétentieux c'est moi voilà
la caméra là bas c'était moi ça fait ces
malfaiteurs
c'est moi bonjour voila on débarque sur
la côte on vient d'arriver
on n'a rien à se mettre alors vous allez
m'habiller évidemment la badr ont donc
on paye pas alors voilà comme on l'est
antilles à gand en jungle ou alors il
faut qu'on s'habille pour l'été je
t'écoute maintenant tu m'avais me met
les lunettes au mollet mais c'est pas
moi qui n'aimais on a 10 de l'atp pisa
montre mlanao si vous allez en fils et
une aquarelle
j'ai pas la porte mais moi je m'en fous
du prix de façon je paye rien moi vous
ne roulez pas ce qui n'a pas marché non
plus aux manutentionnaires
qu est ce qu on dit merci quand même un
podium et un bonjour je vous explique
vous avez noir 1 c'est vous allez nous
payer des glaces à toute l'équipe vous
avez moins de 30 secondes à leurs manies
ghoul qu on n'a pas la journée est ce qu
on dit merci monsieur
allez salut bonne bourre allez on rentre
vous me ferez une montre regardez ça
s'appelle un voyageur donc il me faut un
froch léger et puis autre chose que des
tiags contente
ils m'ont dit merci les deux oui c'est
donc là que j'ai connu cela pas non plus
envelopper les on n'a pas la journée
[Musique]
supplique paniqué a dans ce cas là il
faut demander tu veux nique et madame
gay chez mu ye soit 900 bas ok ça me va
bien
la blouse un peu à terrebonne les bonnes
seul homme bon ce que j'espère c'est que
on va aller chez toi et on va tirer
ok didon s'est dit mal les capotes
tribal a pas d'image de mad 20 combats
le seul truc que j'ai finalement c'est
les capotes dix balles quand même
monique
non sans déconner caspe c'est le truc le
plus cher lancera deux pelles sont les
côtés de monsieur et faut compter
combien pour 66 alors vous faites pas
chier appelez moi le gérant se doutait
c'est vous le patron
donc je vous explique on arrive à saint
tropez on n'a pas de rendre vous allez
nous voir à combien à 19 ans bras 66 x
au nom vous nous mettez sharif cheikh
charif pas cher c'est pas parce qu'on
paye pas qu'il faut mais c'est à dire de
la merde
une bouteille à combien ça 440 30 c'est
pas le meilleur des sponsors officiels
de la maison et on s'en bat les couilles
serre bonjour
enfin un reportage sur les vieux
croûtons bourré de blé il est où
we're in the boss parce qu'il nous a
invités avec l'équipe pour huit jours on
va dormir ici et nous je sais mais il
nous a invités
donc toi ton chèque et à la compta a
donc tu vas tu vas enfin visiter les
pays baltes ou celle du blaireau ce
qu'on va faire on est toute une équipe
nous on va s'installer huit jours ici
d'accord alors pour le menu t'inquiète
pas on mange de tout simplement tu fous
pas le bordel parce qu'on dort jusqu'à
midi d'accord là il ya un yacht de son
ami persyn pas mon avis je vais passer
on se voit je vous appellerai au camping
mais avec un mois je suis avec mes potes
sont pas trop car voici
dormir
les russes
bonjour et amis je sens bien
à l'autriche regardez moi je crois au
combat couvre en quoi rire au nez j'ai
même pas la couleur
j'ai perdu mes lunettes il faut qu'on
aille dans une boutique chercher des
lunettes on va marcher comme si de rien
n'était on va essayer de ne pas se faire
remarquer hal est disponible maintenant
elle est plein de petits qu un
voilà voulez-vous matelas oui voilà et
là vous avez les petites cullin ou et
mater et tous aient compris les petits
culs bagarre tiens encore déclic arrive
regarde encore des cures c'est bourré de
cus vous sentez le pognon aussi qu'on va
vous taxer tous bords ont produit ce
même été volé
il y en a quand même yona s'avoue même
pendant les mauvaises années vous êtes
bons à plumes et installez-vous mais non
madame
on est là pour vous tirer votre blé à
moi je vous le dis je me met en
confiance c'est le but du jeu donc dès
que vous ouvrez votre sac à main
objet rien d'accord voulez un petit
cocktail le gîte rural 800 francs
d'accord le seul truc que je vous
demanderai en cours de saison
quand vous aurez plus de blesser de nous
le dire pour qu on vous vire de la plage
comprennent d'autres gens un plus mais
un ayez l'honnêteté de nous le dire en
cours de saison 1
ça sera pas ici
bon je vais donner le nom vous faites
pas chier que le pourboire de la
gourmette à une boucle d'oreille à vous
n'avez pas reculé de la monnaire tout à
l'heure ils étaient les bonnes laquelle
laquelle je crois vous dit allez bonne
volée patrick roy à l'eau froide que ça
enfin je pense que vous aviez vu une
gamine qui était bonne de parasols
d'accord d'accord ça fait 7 cents à 707
et 1430 parasols
vous allez nique et votre femme vous
même oui ok donc j'ai des commandes
philippe merci philippe il va là il va
les [ __ ] lui-même et c'est pas trop
dur la vie de milliardaire et pas des
moments c'est fatigant des primes en
tout cas j'étais un peu jaune oui mais
maintenant ça facile tout cet argent et
tous les femmes la wii
ces dix ou si un cd c'est aussi un jour
on s'achète un iota gérant sa pêche est
une ville là on va vous [ __ ] les
gonzesses tout le temps tout le temps
c'est ce qu'on va faire un truc moi je
vais faire milliardaire tu vas me filer
tout ton pognon et moi je te filer ma
chemise et tu vas faire plagistes et on
va voir si tu peux refaire un
milliardaire en partant de plagistes est
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
vérifie dans l'eau après les dauphins
les orques et les baleines chaque année
des milliers de taris s'échouent sur les
plages
y'a pas moyen de les ranimer l'a1 a6
regarder la femelle est bouge un peu
encore même enceinte stéphanie de monaco
est obligé de garder l'anonymat grâce à
un chapeau qui la protège des regards
indiscrets et portugais ont séché dans
linge ici une petite culotte et une
grosse capote effiloché alors tu as
trouvé des clefs de ton père les a même
pas pour mais ici je suis pas sa
recherche
qu'est ce que vous mettez vos jumelles
et des mecs vous regardez les regarder
les brâkmar des garçons avec les
jumelles ah non
la région tiens mon oeil la région la
région des testicules
c'est le bateau les petits bateaux vous
avez une petite érection là vous avez vu
une petite érection la france c'est le
tour de france et les filles comment
garder les filles voyez l'antenne elle
se déplie un peu alors vous prouver sur
la plage mais vous avez quand même
importe capote
oui j'ai comme une capote dans le port
de capotes comme une gamine dans une
journée ici sur la côte
aucune vais passer toute une
je sais la retraite monsieur est ce que
vous êtes ce qu'on appelle un amateur
sur la plage non pas du tout
je me prends même journée vous arrivez à
mater combien de niche en moyenne non
nature comme sa copine et amateurs ni
croupit en rien du tout qu'est ce que
vous regardez en premier chez une fille
bon dans l'ensemble un peu tout l'âge
d'or beau poursuit à partir d'un certain
âge on commence à regarder les plus
jeunes et vous êtes tiré comme une
gonzesse depuis que vous êtes là déjà
moi je suis avec mes enfants mon coeur
le monop on dit que dans un couple c'est
l'homme qui porte la culotte mais là
visiblement c'est pas le cas non outils
mais takeda petit bonhomme tes amis ta
culotte il me répond quand je te cause
c'est monsieur un peu dégarni tenteront
de donner la vie à un super beau mâle de
couleur de 23 ans
c'est très très beau des images
magnifiques à les y pousser monsieur
bien sûr que vous êtes là je sais
combien de mètres déjà aucun mec vous
êtes avez combien de mecs déjà à une
quinzaine
j'ai tapé combien de mecs de joie
[Musique]
vous avez changé
[Applaudissements]
18 25 par deux ça fait 36 50 monsieur
s'est multipliée par 2 1
ah si je vous dis regarde ça fait 10 825
vous êtes touristes les vacanciers les
prix multiplié par deux et d'étrangers
par trois arrêts pas vous n'êtes pas
étranger non
donc c'est simplement par deux donc de
18 25 on passe à 36 50 on assomme les
touristes et les étrangers maintenant on
le dit c'est nouveau ces nouveaux qu'on
le dise ah oui mais maintenant moi j'ai
décidé de le dire parce qu on le fait et
sans le dire je trouve pas ça honnête si
mel être honnête avec les gens qu'on la
somme 1 c'est vrai qu'on les vols ou au
moins leur dis maintenant c'est plus
régulier ou pensez pas fait ça tout le
temps madame tout le temps c'est depuis
des plus que la côte d'azur du succès on
vous vole on a trois mois pour vous
voler c'est pas évident parce que là
l'hiver vous venez pas vous ici on n'a
que trois mois pour vous voler encore le
mois de juin est pas facile hein donc on
a vraiment juillet août pour vous tirer
le maximum de pognon quoi des convois
des blaireaux comme vous hop on les
presse comme des citrons coin c'est
marrant de 342 fond monsieur 114 x 3
parce que vous êtes touristes
vous êtes quoi vous êtes suisse allemand
les prix vont regarder monsieur les prix
sont multipliés par deux pour les
vacanciers 23 pour les étrangers
pourquoi ce qu'on est en saison on
assomme de touristes ici monsieur on a
trois mois pour faire de l'argent
vous le savez bien tout le monde le sait
on le marque donc ce après 342 francs
vous allez bien vous êtes volet sur la
côte d'azur monsieur vous le savez bien
un missionnaire bonjour thomas marie
vous mettez le doigt bien profond et
vous sentez après allez-y quoi evans de
maraîchers quoi affligeant ici on pèse
ici on assomme passerait 90
micky
et oui ça fait trente francs vous êtes
tellement s'est multiplié par trois pour
les fridolins regardez c'est du vol
c'est de l'intubation les en tubes dont
les en tube les étrangers en fait comme
ça un tube et entuber et de fait le
droid droid la classe en tube on le
remet dans le cucquois ok voilà faire on
va la refaire traite à savenay watts
non non non aïe stole you your money
because it chez côte d'azur et sur you
as blaireau blaireau said les touristes
au match au mode turbo mode on vous a
bien [ __ ] et on vous remercie
bien sûr si les prix vous seriez
allemand c'était trois fois le prix non
134 me fait pas cent balles
et vous ça vous est arrivé quand
on vous a bien tué c'est pas du tout
moins cher 1 il est propre nom mais les
profs il est propre aux ratés j'avais
petit traîner la cena mais vous avez de
très bons à l'arrière je vérifie l'huile
merci les pneus c'est un petit check up
to c voire un couche tout c'est quoi ça
[ __ ] première poule du boulot je vais
faire un coup à la riaj rappelé
tranquille 1
deux balles ouais deux balles pour le
pare brise sont déconner j'ai plus de
pognon basse flatteur mais les
essuie-glaces et [ __ ] deux balles je
ne crois pas 1 2 53 seroyal démerde-toi
entendent au bal je vais finir parce que
j'ai une conscience - voilà c'est
gratuit c'est gratuit tu m'entends
gratuit je te demande de rien c'est ça
la beauté de l'âme à ces cinq vols par
personne vous êtes 40 souffert de
s'emballe rien que des sales wiimote
hamsik ou sur le sol est trop voilà les
240 de francs pour moi glisse que j'ai
fermé ma caisse des sous mauricette
ouvre je sais que tu es là mauricette je
sais que tu es là vous mettre un petit
coup c'est pour moi c'est la maison qui
offre c'est moi qui régale ça fait
plaisir ça me fait plaisir
voilà c'est mieux mais d'accord olalala
salué comme un i phone
voilà c'est dangereux 1
je préfère les changes serait plus
tranquille un bien pour 400 francs c'est
pas méchant d'accord merci monsieur 50
centimes ça peut être vous manque et 60
centimes non non la la j'ai peur qu'ils
avaient non mais parce que ba ba
battant robert attend quand tu joues
robert hop un bas blanc beur
on sera mieux comme ça ohlala et rtl
c'est le voilà voilà
ça fait tranquille comme ça merci
monsieur 3% blé à mon frère et son
portrait tout craché
les corrections de ne rien rater de
leonard itunes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux